my name is Emil Bruno I'm a postdoctoral
researcher in Rebecca Sachs's lab in
that brain and cognitive sciences
department at MIT the reason that I'm in
this game is that I was a volunteer at a
conflict resolution program and after
the program I saw that for a subset of
the kids it was really successful this
was in Ireland during the Troubles so
the kids in Belfast from the Catholic
neighborhoods would walk to the
Protestant neighborhoods to meet their
new friends which is actually quite a
dangerous activity back then but for
other kids for example for the half of
the kids at the camp a fight broke out
between two of them and it immediately
split the group down partisan lines and
there was a full-scale 150 child brawl
so obviously for that subset of the kids
the camp wasn't particularly successful
so the question I left with was well
what do we know about these programs
which programs work and which don't
why did some kids respond positively and
other kids not and when I came back and
started asking these questions I
realised there was very little there
very little was known and so that's why
I'm here the research program I'm
engaged in Rebecca Saxe is lab was
motivated by my experience with conflict
resolution programs so my goal is to
provide support for these conflict
resolution programs as they try to
understand what effect they're actually
having so there are a number of ways
that we're trying to address this one is
conflict resolution programs have a
number of different components in them
so we want to be able to assess these
little components and we've done this by
trying to establish controlled
experimental paradigms in the field in
regions where conflict exists for
example we've done that in the Middle
East we organised surprise online
conversations between Israelis and
Palestinians because we wanted to see
what aspect of these dialogue programs
that are commonly used what effect of
those have what we found for example is
that the type of intervention that works
best for Israelis does not work for
Palestinians and the intervention that
we're sure Palestinians does not work
for Israelis so this is important
because conflict resolution program
are based on the intuition that the same
intervention should be used across the
board for both participants so this is
one of the benefits I think that
evidence-based approaches can give they
can actually test these assumptions to
see whether they're true or not another
set of measures we're using are
neuroimaging measures and the goal of
that is to find neural markers of these
psychological biases that once we have a
neural marker for it we can then see if
the program affects that neural process
over the course of the program so one of
the things that we've been focused on is
the role of narratives in intergroup
conflicts if you ask Israelis and
Palestinians to explain why a barrier
was built by Israel around the West Bank
they have very different narratives
about that event they respond very
strongly to each other's narrative they
think that their narrative is reasonable
and rational and true and that the other
side's narrative is not only untrue but
completely irrational to believe so what
you can have people do to look at this
bias is you can have them read about
their own narratives and about the other
side's narratives and then you see how
their brain is responding to these
narratives and what we found is that
there is a good neural marker of the
response to these narratives the amount
of response in this brain region tracks
with how strongly they feel about the
other group another line of research is
on empathy one of the things that
characterizes intergroup conflicts is
that there's a big empathy gap between
an group and out-group and this gap
seems to be particularly important so
not just the empathy for the out-group
but not just the empathy for the
in-group of the the difference between
the two the way I'm looking at the nura
mission is twofold
so one it just is inherently interesting
to me to see these neural processes to
see if they're localized to see where
they are and what they interact with in
the brain so that that's just the
interesting component the potentially
important component is if we can get a
neural signature of these psychological
processes then we have a measure that we
can't get otherwise and that allows us
then to assess the effect of
intervention
that are aimed at decreasing that bias